c'est une première depuis huit ans
l'armée syrienne a mis la manière sur
les dernières poches qui était détenu
par les djihadistes autour d'alès le
président syrien bachar el-assad engagé
à poursuivre l'offensive dans le
nord-ouest du pays pour libérer l'ultime
grand bastion tenu par les djihadistes
et les rebelles les précisions avec
rania berrada ce n'était pas arrivé
depuis 2012 l'armée syrienne vient de
reprendre le contrôle de 28 poche
jusque-là aux mains des groupes
islamistes en banlieue d'alep annonce de
l'agencé de presse publique syrienne
sana
dans une allocution le porte parole de
l'armée syrienne s'est félicité du
succès de l'opération
les héros de l'armée arabe syrienne ont
poursuivi leur avancée
déterminé à déraciner le terrorisme des
mécréants et à chasser les tueurs armés
qui voulaient confisquer la volonté de
notre peuple dans la région il les
prenait en otage et les utiliser comme
des boucliers humains afin d'entraver
l'avancée de l'armée et de retarder la
fin de ces factions armées qui sont des
factions terroristes selon le droit
international
nos braves soldats ont un conflit leur
mission avec une grande efficacité et en
un temps record des dizaines de villages
et de villes sont de nouveau sous le
contrôle du gouvernement
à l'ouest et au nord-ouest d'alep
toujours selon l'agencé sana les
combattants djihadistes se sont retirés
de leurs avants postes vers la frontière
turque
il laisse ainsi la totalité de la
périphérie d'alep aux mains des forces
de bachar el-assad une route stratégique
reliant damas et alep avec ses centres
industriels a également été reprise aux
rebelles dimanche soir à l'annoncé de ce
succès militaires des scènes de liesse
ont éclaté dans la ville les habitants
d'alep se disent soulagés du départ des
groupes jihadistes c'est grâce à dieu
grâce à nos prières grâce à l'armée
arabe syrienne
que dieu les protège et face qu'ils
retrouvent leur famille vous êtes la
meilleure armée du monde
vous avez mis à genoux les états unis
vous avez mis à genoux les turcs et tous
les envahisseurs et nous sommes fiers de
vous vous êtes la syrie vous avez appris
au monde le sens du mot liberté
le président syrien bachar al assad
s'est engagé ce lundi à poursuivre
l'offensive dans le nord-ouest du pays
pour libérer l'ultime grand bastion tenu
par les djihadistes une déclaration qui
intervient alors que l'eau est nu
réitère ses appels pour un cessez le feu
dans la région d'idlib
selon les nations-unies dans cette zone
les combats et frappes aériennes ont
fait plus de 900 mille déplacés depuis
décembre